lei comunque voce stupenda ma non arriva
per niente Questa è la dimostrazione che
tu puoi cantare bene quanto vuoi ma se
non emozioni il pubblico tu non sei un
cantante Oddio che calante o c'è un
problema in cuffia ragazzi Ma di cosa
stiamo parlando ma lei è la regina del
vibrato Ma senti
che bravino si è perso un po' nel finale
Ma vabbè comunque sia Sanremo eh
L'emozione gioca brutti scherzi non
capisco questo Trend della voce
graffiata col graffio o ci nasci cioè
perché forzare perché questa esigenza
Comunque se ci pensi tutti questi
produzioni si basano tutti sulle stesse
tre note na na na na stessi accordi è di
quella di quest'estate girati al
contrario cioè conli stessi accordi ci
vanno 10 canzoni Eh no dai